A BULLDOG ATTORNEY TO HIS TEAM.
>> Bret: KEVIN CORKE LIVE ON
THE NORTH LAWN.
THANK YOU.
LET'S GET SOME PERSPECTIVE.
SENIOR POLITICAL ANALYST
BRIT HUME IS HERE WITH US
TONIGHT.
GOOD EVENING, BRIT.
>> HIGH MAX, BRET.
>> Bret: FIRST, LET'S START
WITH McCABE, THE FALLOUT FROM
THE FIRING, AND WHAT HAS
TRANSPIRED OVER THE LAST COUPLE
OF DAYS.
>> BRET, I SEE VERY LITTLE BASIS
BASED ON WHAT WE KNOW NOW TO
THINK THAT THIS FIRING WAS ANY
THING BUT ON THE UP AND UP.
THIS INQUIRY THAT GREW OUT OF
IT, THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S
INVESTIGATION HAS BEEN GOING ON
BACK BEFORE TRUMP WAS PRESIDENT.
IT CAME ACROSS THINGS ABOUT
McCABE, LEAKS THAT HE WAS
INVOLVED IN, AND THEN THE LACK
OF CANDOR AS IT WAS PUT.
TO INVESTIGATORS ABOUT IT.
THAT IS A VERY BIG DEAL INSIDE
THE FBI.
THE MATTER WAS -- THAT PIECE OF
IT -- WAS PASSED TO THE FBI'S
OWN OFFICE OF PROFESSIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY, WHICH LOOKED AT
IT, AND RECOMMENDED THAT
McCABE BE FIRED.
THERE'S BEEN A LOT OF CRITICISM
AT THE FIRING WAS RUSHED BUT
McCABE WAS ON THE VERGE OF
RETIREMENT, AFTER WHICH HE COULD
NOT BE FIRED.
SO THE FIRING CAME AT THE VERY
LAST MINUTE.
IT SEEMS TO ME THAT FAR FROM
BEING RUSHED, IT MAY HAVE BEEN
HELD OFF UNTIL THEY WERE FACING
A DEADLINE AFTER WHICH SHE
COULDN'T BE FIRED.
IT LOOKS TO ME IT'S ON THE UP
AND UP.
WE WANT TO KNOW EVERYTHING UNTIL
THE INSPECTOR GENERAL'S REPORT
COME OUT.
WE WILL KNOW MORE ABOUT THE
FACTS UPON WHICH IT WAS BASED.
IT LOOKS OKAY TO ME.
>> Bret: TALKING TO SENATORS
GRASSLEY AND GRAHAM LAST WEEK,
THE LIST OF QUESTIONS THEY HAD
AND CALLING FOR A SPECIAL
COUNSEL SEEMS LIKE THEY KNOW
MUCH MORE ABOUT WHAT IS A MET
IG'S REPORT THAT IS UPCOMING.
TO MUELLER OUTCOME OF THE TALK
AROUND TOWN IS THE QUESTION, IS
THE PRESIDENT GOING TO FIRE
MUELLER OR SOMEHOW SET THE STAGE
FOR THAT.
YOUR THOUGHTS?
>> HE CERTAINLY DIDN'T STOP HIM
FOR HIS CRITICISM OF MUELLER.
AS WE NOTED EARLIER, WE MENTION
HIM BY NAME.
THAT IS PROVOKED TO SPECULATION
THAT HE'S ABOUT TO DROP THE
HAMMER ON HIM.
I HAVE MY DOUBTS, BRET.
I NOTICE THAT TY COBB WHO SPEAKS
FOR THE PRESIDENT SAID, IN THE
LAST 24 HOURS, THAT HE HAD NO
PLANS OR ISN'T EVEN DISCUSSING
DOING IT.
OF COURSE THE PRESIDENT MUST BE
AWARE THAT THE LAST TIME THAT
WAS TRIED WAS MY RICHARD NIXON
DEALING WITH A SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR AND THE CONSEQUENCES
OF THAT WAS THAT HE GOT ANOTHER
SPECIAL PROSECUTOR IN THE
INVESTIGATION WENT ON AND LED
ULTIMATELY TO WHERE HE WAS UP ON
THE VERGE OF BEING IMPEACHED.
I SUSPECT HE'S AWARE THAT
GETTING RID OF THIS SPECIAL
PROSECUTOR BLOOD -- OR THE
SPECIAL COUNSEL -- WOULD ONLY
GENERATE ANOTHER ONE AND HE
WOULD BE RIGHT WHERE HE STARTED
FROM.
>> Bret: THIS IS NOT
UNPRECEDENTED.
>> NO, IT'S NOT UNPRECEDENTED.
IT DIDN'T TURN OUT VERY WELL FOR
THE PRESIDENCY TO THE FIRING.
>> Bret: RIGHTS.
AS FAR AS THE PUBLIC TALK OF A
SPECIAL COUNSEL, YOU COVERED A
WHITE HOUSE WHICH DID NOT, AS
WELL.
>> WE CERTAINLY -- THE STUFF WE
ARE HEARING SAID, WITCH HUNT, AS
KEVIN CORKE POINTED OUT IN HIS
REPORT, THIS APPEARS TO BE RIGHT